la réglementation européenne tout comme
l'été la réglementation française quand
c'était nationale c'est un atout pour la
solidité d'un système c'est à dire que
on évite alors là encore je vais
utiliser un terme et je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il existe en français le terme de
dumping le dumping réglementaire c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
négatif et qui a pu poser beaucoup de
difficultés et donc dans beaucoup de
secteurs d'activité aujourd'hui on peut
faire une activité similaire à celle des
banques sans être soumis à la même
réglementation on ne fait pas exactement
la même chose mais on fait une bonne
partie de choses ou alors on peut
exercer le même métier mais tout
simplement le faire dans un autre pays
avec des règles différentes moins 10 ans
bon et s'agissant de l'Union européenne
les banques françaises effectivement ont
été extrêmement critiques sur la
proportionnalité sur l'utilisation de la
proportionnalité pour exempter un
certain nombre de banques
et par ailleurs nous souhaitons
également que cette réglementation
correspondent à la réalité du
fonctionnement des banques européennes
je reprends mon exemple tout à l'heure
sur
s'il vous plaît je reprends mon exemple
sur le crédit immobilier atofix c'est
vrai que les règles internationales
quand elles sont élaborées elles sont
élaborées avec une référence mondiale
qui est que le crédit à taux variable
c'est moins risqué vue du point de vue
de la banque que le crédit à taux fixe
et donc quand vous êtes un pays où vous
faites beaucoup plus de crédit à taux
fixe que la moyenne internationale ce
qui est le cas de la France et bien
quand il y a une règle internationale
elle va pas forcément je dirais vous
conduire à bien gérer vos risques elle
va plutôt vous conduire à finalement
changer de modèle et à vous dire il y a
un modèle qui va me devenir très coûteux
pour moi et l'autre qui ne l'est pas
donc tout le cœur de nos interventions
sur les questions de réglementation
bancaire sont d'être bien certain quand
on applique en Europe une règle
internationale qu'elle correspond à la
fois dans son contenu et dans ses
paramètres à finalement à la vraie
pratique bancaire européenne et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui il y a des écarts
très importants entre les États-Unis et
l'Europe et que effectivement cette
norme internationale qui pour
schématiser très largement pour
schématiser on pourrait passer des
heures à l'expliquer mais pour
schématiser elle est faite pour un
modèle globalement anglo-saxon malgré
tous les efforts qu'on fait les
négociateurs européens et au fond quand
elle s'appliquent effectivement il faut
quand même que ça couvre vraiment le
risque européen donc la proportionnalité
l'adaptation à nos risques c'est un
élément qui je pense est important